so the density of a white dwarf if you
took a cup
of material from a white dwarf it would
have the mass of about an elephant
well in astronomy we get to deal with
the extremes of density
so if we talk about the density of the
universe as a whole
we think that the average density across
the whole universe is about 10 to the
minus 27. now that's a number that we
can't really get a handle on even as
astronomers but one way to think about
it is that if all the mass were spread
out evenly you would go around you would
encounter about one atom of hydrogen per
every cubic meter
that's how empty space is space is
really very very empty
okay so a benchmark for density that we
can think of here on earth is water
so one liter of water weighs about one
kilogram so in the units we've been
looking at here we're talking about a
thousand kilograms per meter squared so
if you have a box that measures one
meter on each side you fill it with
water that weighs a thousand kilograms
or a ton
so a star about the mass of our sun will
leave behind something that we call a
white dwarf which is a very strange
object but also very dense
so the density of a white dwarf
is
about 10 to the 8 kilograms per meter
squared so 100
million kilograms per meter squared
but we can go even much denser neutron
stars are the in states of stars that
when a star's gone through its entire
life and just sort of collapse down to
nothing
sometimes you'll end up with one of
these very compact objects so you'll end
up with something that has the entire
mass of a star like the sun for example
compressed into a region maybe 10
kilometers across
and this is a kind of object where the
matter has been squeezed together so
tightly
that all of the protons and electrons in
the atoms have basically fused together
to become neutrons so it's just a huge
ball of neutrons it's essentially an
enormous giant
nucleus of an atom you take that much
mass and compress it down into such a
small region remember density is the
mass divided by the volume and now
you've got a very big mass in a very
small volume so if you divide a big
number by a very small number you end up
with a huge number so something about
the size of a small city and this is
these are some of the highest densities
that that we can comprehend now so if
you calculate the density of one of
these neutron stars for example you end
up with a figure of around 10 billion
tonnes per teaspoonful so if you took a
teaspoon full of neutron star it would
weigh about 10 billion tons so when i
learned about these concepts in at
university the professor that i had
tried to make these more accessible to
us so for white dwarf the first object
that i talked about he translated those
densities into elephants per cup so the
density of a white dwarf if you took a
cup
of material from a white dwarf it would
have the mass of about an elephant
so you'd have to take an elephant
something you know several tons and
squeeze that matter down into something
of this kind of volume
now for a neutron star of course the
densities are even even greater for a
neutron star the unit that we learned
about was mount everest per teaspoonful
so in this case you take the mass of
mount everest the mass of a mountain and
you squeeze it down into a very very
small volume
and that's the density that you have in
a neutron star so if you took a teaspoon
full of material from a neutron star it
would weigh about as much as mount
everest well one of the other things
that tends to go along with neutron
stars is they have very very strong
magnetic fields and so
the magnetic field is so so high that
you actually end up the magnetic field
ends up beaming light and so one of the
properties of a neutron star is it can
actually beam light very effectively so
we've just been playing around with some
ways to
sort of
visualize these densities that we've
been talking about so we've taken some
objects some normal objects from any
scientist
office so a coffee cup being a very
important part of the scientific process
and we're just
imagining that we're filling this coffee
cup up with paper clips at a rate of
about one every second the other thing
that stars do is they rotate and neutron
stars actually rotate very fast um just
because they they conserve their angular
momentum so just like an ice skater
spins faster and faster as they pull
their arms in so if you collapse a star
down to a neutron star it spins faster
and faster and faster so you can have a
star rotating a thousand times a second
and so it has one of these beams of
light rotating a thousand times a second
so you just end up with a lighthouse
effect that the thing can flash past you
a thousand times a second so what you
actually see are very very rapid flashes
of light every time the thing rotates
so we figured that with this pile of
paper clips here it would take us a few
minutes the rate of one every second to
fill this cup up when they're when
they're rotating in this way they tend
to get called pulsars and the way main
way people detect pulsars is with radio
telescopes if you point a radio
telescope at the sky you can detect
hundreds if not thousands of pulsars
now let's imagine that we wanted to
reach the densities that we were talking
about for white dwarfs and neutron stars
if we were to do this of course we'd
have to pack the paper clips in much
much tighter we'd have to squeeze them
in
and if we keep kept doing this at the
rate of one paper clip per second
squeezing them all together
to get the densities that we see in a
white dwarf
uh we'd need probably about almost eight
million paper clips into that into that
one cup into that one cup and of course
doing this at a rate of one per second
this would take us about 80 or 90 days
without sleeping without stopping
without resting at all we'd have to do
this for 87 80 80 to 90 days and for
neutron star if we were to continue this
experiment
we would actually need
seven quadrillion paper clips this time
squeezed into the same volume the same
cup we would need to squeeze in seven
quadrillion paper clips
and doing it at the same rate of one
paper clip per second that would take me
220 million years should this be giving
some people some indication of how much
empty space there is in inside atoms
oh absolutely just like in outer space
inner space the space within atoms is
mostly empty we live in a very very
empty universe both on large scales and
on strong small scales so there's a lot
of room in here in these individual
atoms there's a lot of room to compress
them down in in into smaller units um
but that's not the kind of compression
that we're able to do
here on earth we like i said we need
these astronomical processes to actually
reach these really enormous densities
yeah so not everything in in astronomy
is very very dense we also have very
underdense objects as well we talked
about water being 1 000 kilograms per
cubic meter but if we look at an object
like saturn which is mostly a great big
ball of gas so saturn being one of the
planets in our solar system it's a great
big ball of gas and a cubic meter of
saturn
would only be about 700 kilograms per
cubic meter that's that's less dense
than water which means of course if you
were able to construct a bathtub large
enough to contain saturn saturn would
actually float
so some of the some some planets like
earth are very dense they're they're
rocky but some of the outer planets like
saturn are very very
they're just big balls of gas
and if you could put them in a bathtub
they would float